[Music]
you're probably the most difficult thing
I've ever done is ascend Mount Everest
and it might come as a surprise it's
very hard to to get to become an
astronaut and trained for mission and go
fly a mission but the the psychological
difference of being on Mount Everest is
pretty substantial when you're in in
space you're inside your spacecraft
you're you're comfortable you're in
shirtsleeves it's it's warm I have three
square meals a day
you're not hypoxic you're not
malnourished up on Mount Everest every
second of every day you're feeling that
the thinning air you you can't get
enough calories in your body you need
five or six thousand calories a day just
to break even and so you feel the life
threat every every minute of every day
there are avalanches that come calving
down off of the the walls around the
circle Everest base camp and so you know
you you feel that cumulative
psychological stress of you know you're
in a really dangerous place on a special
mission in contrast you feel the threat
obviously on the launch you know you've
got 7 million pounds of thrust you know
taking you off of the planet but then
it's it's very beautiful and peaceful
you're in this extraordinary a
glass-bottom boat looking at your home
planet and you you feel like you're the
luckiest person alive and and so the
only other time that you feel perhaps
some degree of trepidation is floating
outside that hatch and going out into
the vacuum of space on a spacewalk but
for the most part yeah being in space is
just a peaceful relaxing disarming kind
of a place whereas the the mental toll
in the physical toll of Everest is is
pretty exceptional certainly on Everest
you're you're out there more or less on
your own you have a small team a cadre
of folks that you're with and I had the
good fortune to be with about 20
climbers on my team and my my sidekick
was de niro Sherpa from fort say just
one of the most amazing athletes in
Mountaineers in the world he's now
summited Mount of
sixteen times I used to joke him all the
time that he he had three lungs and two
hearts because he could just kind of run
up most parts of Everest summit day
however was a great equalizer he was
used very much suffering just as much as
I was but you're pretty much left to
your own resources no one can carry you
down from summit day on Mount Everest
you're gonna do it under your own power
or you'll add to the 250 souls that are
left on the side of the mountain so it's
it's pretty sobering and you've got to
have your wits about you so yeah I think
that that also weighs heavily in terms
of the the psyche of being high in the
mountains versus you know being in space
where you have this brilliant team of
engineers and flight controllers in
Houston and around the world kind of
looking over your shoulder and if things
start to go south you know you've got
the a-team at your back
[Music]